the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so you guys asked to do some numerical
examples of the stuff that we've been
learning today and I've got a fun one
for you a very real one because it
happens all the time in reactors all
over the world so to set the stage for
this they suppose I had a you know just
suppose I had a radioactive cobalt-60
source that was calibrated in March 2011
to be approximately 1 micro curie and
it's now October 2016 so let's start off
with the easy part let's say I posed the
question how active was this source
actually when it was made because it
just says what does it say 1 micro Curie
and supposedly it was one micro Curie on
March 2011 what does that mean the
actual activity could be there's not a
lot of confidence in that number who
remembers significant figures from high
school chemistry and physics this is
when they're important because you got
to know what you're buying so what is
the actual activity of this source when
it was calibrated what is our
uncertainty on this anyone remember this
from sig figs I hope so not I'll refresh
your memory it's plus or minus the next
decimal point so really this was 1 plus
or minus 0.5 micro Kure so you might
have 1/2 micro Curie source you might
have a 1 and 1/2 micro Curie source they
specifically decided to leave out the
second decimal point so they're not
liable for a source that's out of that
calibration level so we supposedly have
a 1 micro Curie source and I've measured
it on let's say it's now October 2016
suppose I went and made a measurement
and it was point 5 2 micro Curie's and
we want to know how active was this
source actually when we got it where
would I begin
okay yeah that's why I've got the table
of nuclides right here so let's look up
the half-life of cobalt-60 and there it
is right there 1925 days so we know that
the half-life for cobalt 60 is nineteen
twenty five point four days which equals
and I pre did the math out that I
wouldn't spend lots of time on the
calculator activity how many seconds is
that one point six six times ten to the
eighth seconds and we also remember that
activity equation where the activity as
a function of time equals the original
activity times e to the minus lambda T
the only thing missing here is the
initial activity in lambda so how do we
find lambda and remember remember that
expression yep and we know that lambda
equals log of two over the half-life
which in this case is about 0.693 nine
over one point six six times ten to the
eighth which equals four point one seven
times ten to the minus nine per second
and so now it's pretty easy we know what
lambda is we know what our current a is
so we can say that our original activity
is simply our current activity divided
by e to the minus lambda T what's T well
I made an approximation here it's been
about five years and seven months I
assumed that a month has 30 days on
average which comes out to T
I remember calculating this already one
point seven four times ten to the eighth
a second
so we plug in that T right here plug in
that lambda right there and we get our
initial activity what did I get was 1.07
micro Curie's now hopefully this result
is fairly intuitive because the
half-life of cobalt 57 is 1925 days
which is about five and a quarter years
and it's just over five and a quarter
years since this source was calibrated
and we have just under half of the
original activity so hopefully that's an
intuitive numerical example now let's
say how many atoms of cobalt 60 did we
have or better yet what was the mass of
cobalt 60 where would I go for that
give you a hint it's on the screen yeah
so for this plastic check source right
here what's the actual mass of cobalt-60
that we put in in the beginning again
supposing I had one of these right in
front of you you could look at binding
energy which is a form of mass or
luckily we've got the atomic mass right
up there in AMU so again this is a quick
review of high school chemistry we need
to find out how many atoms we have in
this pellet and once we know the number
of atoms and we have the molar mass up
there and either amu per atom or same
thing as moles per gram pretty much
we'll know what the mass of cobalt-60
was so one important conversion factor
to note is that one curie of radiation
is three point seven times ten to the
ten Beca rel and remember that one
becker l is one disintegration per
second
so if we know the initial activity of
our material using our decay constant we
should know the number of atoms that we
had right there so we know our initial
activity a naught is 1.07 micro curie
and anyone remember what's the relation
between the activity and the number of
atoms present just yell it out hope
you'd know that by now this look
familiar to anyone where the activity is
directly proportional to the number of
atoms there times its decay constant so
since we now know a naught we can find
n-not because now we know lambda as well
so the number of atoms we had at the
beginning is just our activity over
lambda and our activity is 1.07 micro
Curie's let's convert up to Curie's so
we know that there is one Curie in 10 to
the 6 micro Curie's and we'll use that
conversion factor right there times
three point seven times ten to the ten
becquerels per one Curie divided by our
decay constant four point one seven
times ten to the minus nine for a second
let's check our units to make sure
everything comes out we have a micro
curious on the that's right I brought a
canceling color we have micro Curie's on
the top micro Curie's on the bottom
Curie's on the top Curie's on the bottom
and we have a becker ELLs which is a
disintegrations per second and we have a
per second down on the bottom so the per
second goes away and the becquerels just
becomes atoms
and so we actually get and not is I
think we say something times 10 to the
12th yeah nine point five times ten to
the twelfth Adams that's the way it was
so the final step how do we go for a
number of atoms to mass anyone tell me
yep so the last thing we'll do is we'll
say we have nine point five times ten to
the twelfth atoms times Avogadro's
number which is one mole in every six
times 10 to the 23rd atoms and then we
go to the table of nuclides to get its
atomic mass this is one of those
situations where you don't need to take
the eighth decimal place because you're
not calculating you're not converting
from mass to energy you're just getting
mass so if you might wonder where did
all the decimal points go think of what
type of calculation we're doing if we
started off with a one significant digit
number do we really care about keeping
the eighth decimal place and the rest of
everything
no definitely not we're not turning a mu
into MeV in which case the sixth decimal
point could put you off by half an MeV
or like the rest mass of the electron
we're just getting masses here so let's
just call that fifty nine point nine
that's enough for me fifty nine point
nine grams in one mole of cobalt 60 and
just to confirm we have atoms here atoms
there moles there holes there and we
should get a mass in grams and this came
out to 0.95 nano grams of cobalt 60 not
a lot of cobalt 60 can pack quite a
wallop in terms of activity so even
though this has a pretty long half-life
as far as isotopes go it takes very
little of it to have quite a bit of
activity certainly enough for our fairly
inefficient handmade Geiger counter to
what's going on pretty neat huh cool now
let's say I ask you another question a
simpler question how many
disintegrations per second are coming
out of that cobalt-60 source let's say
we wanted to find the efficiency of our
Geiger counter you'd have to know how
many counts you measure you'd have to
know how far away your source is and
you'd have to know how many
disintegrations per second are happening
so how do I get to the number of
disintegrations per second that's right
well just take our current activity
which is 0.5 to micro Curie's and so
we'll say point 0.5 2 times 10 to the
minus 6 Curie's times three point seven
times ten to the ten Becquerel in 1
Curie is well we have curious here we
have Curie's there and this comes out to
what was our current activity was in the
tens of thousands but 19,000 barrels so
we know that right now this source is
giving off about 19,000 disintegrations
per second is that how many gamma rays
it's giving off do we know that yet why
not I heard a lot of knows what other
information do we need to know sure
luckily we've got that right here so if
you look here the mode of decay is beta
decay to nickel 60 so cobalt 60 is
actually primarily a beta source however
it's used for its characteristic gamma
rays so let's take a quick look if we
look at its decay diagram it's pretty
simple and let's just say somewhere near
a hundred percent of the time it beta
decays upto this energy level and can
undergo any number of transitions like
this the only two we really tend to see
is like
that one and that one are the most
likely ones so on average each
disintegration of a cobalt-60 atom is
going to produce two highly energetic
gamma rays
so actually what you'd have to know for
this source is despite it being nineteen
thousand Becker ELLs of cobalt-60 it's
giving off 38,000 gamma rays per second
so that way your source calculations
wouldn't be off by a factor of two then
if you know the distance between your
source and your detector and you know
how many of those gamma rays are going
through the detector itself which we can
count calculate with a solid angle
formula which I'll give you a little
later you'll know how many of them
should interact in here once you learn
photon nuclear interactions and you'll
know how many of them actually get
captured and that's how you can get the
efficiency of the detector so we've kind
of filled in half the puzzle you now
know for a fixed source how many atoms
there are how many disintegrations there
are and how many gamma rays you expect
it to give off and then later in the
course we'll tell you how to figure out
how many of them make it into the
detector and how many of those should
interact in the detector does everyone
clear on what we talked about here yep
[Music]
double the number of cobalt
disintegrations
so yep so I'm I'm ignoring the point O
two and point O six percent decays
because they're extremely unlikely and
having looked this up ahead of time I
know that this transition and that
transition are by far the most likely
ones and if you don't know that sure do
those right there the 99.9 something
intensity ones it's all there so I had
some questions on Piazza what happens
when we can't read the pixilated decay
diagram that's just there for fun the
actual table that will tell you all the
information you need to know is right
below and I just decided all right
forget the ones that are to e to the
minus six likely or 0.007 whatever too
many zeros so you can say that on air
- probably two or three significant
digits that gamma ray and that gamma ray
are the only ones you tend to see is
everyone clear on how I made that
determination cool yes
and each one of those that's right the
number of disintegrations is the number
of atoms that leave this position so
let's take a crazier example but I've
already had you look at americium-241
sort of bring home the message that the
number of americium disintegrations does
not necessarily equal the number of
gamma rays that you will expect to see
because any one of these is possible
there's an 84% likely one that looks
like it goes to the third level from the
bottom because it's just a third number
I'm seeing here if you don't believe
that then check how much you have to
zoom out to see what's going on here
right let's see intensity yep the third
most energetic alpha ray so the third
from the bottom is indeed the 84% likely
one then there's another one that's 13%
likely so we can't discount that either
so you're gonna hit anything from like
the second to the fourth energy level
and any number of those gamma cascades
that come off there so the intensity of
your source in Becker ELLs or Curie's
does not immediately tell you how many
gamma rays or other disintegration
products you should expect there are
some pretty simple ones like the
dysprosium one that we saw was it like
150 one I've been here before it's not
purple no that's a complicated one all
right don't remember which dysprosium
isotope just had a single decay but the
only time that you would get one
particle per disintegration is if your
decay diagram looked like this
that's your parent and that's your
daughter that's the only time you can
expect one thing if you have a more
complex two K diagram than that you'll
be looking at more than one quantum of
radiation of some form per
disintegration so is that unclear to
anybody
cool now let's get into a more fun
problem and I'll leave this up here
since we're gonna refer to it a fair bit
so this is a good example of activity
half-life mass number of atom
calculations we're gonna use this
information to answer a more interesting
question how is this made anyone have
any idea what sort of intentional
nuclear reaction could have produced
cobalt-60 and I'll go back to cobalt 60s
we can get its proton number all right
you say a little louder sure you can
have a neutron bombardment so you can
have cobalt 59 absorbs a neutron becomes
cobalt 60 with some half-life and then
will decay with some decay constant
lambda and become in this case it
undergoes beta decay to nickel 60 let me
make sure I got the proton number right
going from memory here
hooray okay how do we set up the series
radioactive decay and production
equations to describe this phenomenon so
we have a physical picture of what's
going on here how do we construct the
differential equation model the same way
we've been doing it Friday and Tuesday
so someone kicked me off what do we
start with
[Music]
okay destruction times flux
[Music]
okay let's make a couple of designations
let's call cobalt 59 I'll use another
color for this just so it's clear we'll
call cobalt 59 and one we'll call it
cobalt 60 and to coal nickel 60 and
three just to keep our notation straight
and then continuing our notation pile
here you mentioned that there's going to
be some Sigma some microscopic cross
section times some flux the number of
neutrons whizzing about the reactor
times the amount of cobalt 60 so let's
stick our DN 1 DT equals no production
minus some destruction does this look
eerily familiar to any of you forget the
fact that it's a sigma and a flux just
treat those as constants what does this
look exactly like exactly it looks just
like DN 1 DT equals minus lambda and 1
right yeah that's exactly it
this in effect is like your artificially
induced decay so the probability that
one atom of N 1 absorbs a neutron times
the number of neutrons are there gives
you some rate at which these atoms are
destroyed just like a lambda gives you
the rate at which those atoms naturally
self-destruct so you can think of this
Sigma times flux like a lambda
mathematically they're treated
identically the only difference is we're
imposing this Neutron flux so it's like
an artificial lambda which means solving
the equations and setting them up is
exactly the same so how about n 2 what's
the production and destruction rate of
12 volt 60 first of all someone yell it
out what's the
creation rate which lambda so what is
lambda 1 this one yeah okay so let's
keep with these these notations will say
I'm gonna say this is like a lamb to
artificial biome to keep with Sigma flux
and 1 and just so we keep our notations
straight I want to be able to cleanly
separate the natural and the artificial
production and destruction and what's
the destruction rate they said Sigma Phi
n 2 is that the physical picture we have
up here
not quite because like we can see here
cobalt-60 self-destructs on its own
right yeah so however that actually is a
correct term to put in the other one
that we're missing would be minus lambda
n - okay so you know what let's let's
escalate this a bit into reality and say
we're going to we're gonna do this it's
the actual equation is not gonna be that
much harder so thanks Sean but let's do
this yeah yes good question that's what
I was getting to so there is an
absorption cross-section for every
reaction for every isotope and now I'd
like to show you guys where to find them
on the 2201 site there is a link to
what's called the Janus database which
is tabulated and plottable
cross-sections of all kinds so every
single database that we know of it's
updated continuously by the OECD so you
can trust that the data is updated I
won't say accurate because some of these
cross-sections are not very well known
so I've already started it up in this
case we don't have Neutron capture data
for cobalt-60 let's keep it in the
symbols for now and then later on we're
just going to say it's probably zero but
let's keep it together so for cobalt 59
let's double click on that and you are
presented with an enormous host of
possible reactions like right here you
have n comma total which is the total
cross-section for all interactions of
neutrons with cobalt 59 and you can see
that this varies with the same sort of
shape that I was haphazardly drawing
it's low there are some resonances and
then it continuously increases at lower
energies is this the right cross-section
to use if it accounts for every possible
interaction of a neutron with cobalt 59
no so what other reactions besides the
one that we want which is capture could
this account for yep
scattering vision end-to-end production
sometimes one Neutron goes in and to
come out like for beryllium like we
talked about the beginning of class so
you've got to know to choose the right
cross-section and in nuclear reaction
parlance that shorthand right there
that's n comma total that accounts for
elastic scattering inelastic scattering
to any energy level
capture fission end-to-end reactions
sometimes proton release sometimes
exploding whatever nuclei do so let's
look at our other choices shrink that we
have the elastic cross-section compare
that with a total and you get a general
idea of how much the total and elastic
cross-sections actually matter so a lot
of those resonances are elastic
cross-section residences but there are
other reactions that are responsible for
a lot of the other craziness going on so
let's unselect that oh I'm sorry I'm an
empty one let's compare mt1 and mt2 so
mt2 elastic ah there we go
okay that's what I was hoping for so
right now the red one is the total
cross-section and the green one is the
elastic cross section and you can see
that at high energies the total cross
section is mostly the elastic cross
section but at low energies especially
right around here at the thermal energy
of neutrons and a reactor there's
something else responsible that's
probably what we're going after so let's
keep looking through this janice
database hey there's the end-to-end
reaction if you guys want to see how
likely this is it's another one of those
reactions that look at that it's zero
until you get to eleven MeV so what do
you guys think the Q value for
end-to-end production of cobalt 59 is
very how negative it's on the graph yeah
negative looks like 10 or maybe ten and
a half MeV oh hey awesome so there you
go yeah indeed it's very energetically
unlikely to produce to fire in one
neutrons and get to but if you have a
ten point four five four MeV Neutron you
can make it happen
pretty cool huh that's not the reaction
we're going for what we want let's see
if I can find it
proton plus Neutron Neutron plus
deuteron all the in elastic energy
levels there it is capture the gamma
reaction here is what's referred to as
capture and there we go a nice
normal-looking cross-section so for
cobalt 59 if we go down to about 0.025
evie here read it off it's about 20
barns because you guys asked for a
numerical example so let's say that our
capture cross section for cobalt 59 is
about 20 barns which is to say 20 times
10 to the minus 24 centimeters squared
let's also put up our capture one for
cobalt 60 so let's go back to our table
take a look at cobalt 60 I think I know
what the answer is going to be which is
we don't know not in this database
unfortunately so for symbolism let's
keep it there but we're gonna say well
we don't know yeah so let's designate
these different cross sections let's
call it Sigma 59 Sigma 59 and Sigma 60
so those will be our two cross sections
we'll just call this one Sigma 59 we
call this one Sigma 60
and we already know the lambda for
cobalt-60 so let's say the lambda for a
60 cobalt from this stuff up here four
point one seven times ten to the minus
nine per second let's just refer to that
as lambda for ease of writing things
down so we've got a complete set of
reactions for a DN 2 DT what about DN 3
what's the production rate of n 3 yep
lambda n 2 anything else what about the
destruction rate is what it's a stable
isotope but you're on to it Shawn so
what would you add based on what you
added to end to
yeah there's gonna be some new Sigma
let's call it Sigma nickel 65 and 3 find
out let's go to our tables there there's
data for nickel 60
let's look up its absorption
cross-section so we'll scroll down to
our Z gamma our capture cross-section
plot it take a look at around 1 minus 8
and it's like two barns not negligible
so our capture cross-section for nickel
60 keep overriding myself and then I
remember it's a blackboard two barns
which is tell you 2 times 10 to the
minus 24 cm squared so we can just refer
to that as Sigma nickel for the purposes
of this problem we don't particularly
care how much nickel 60 we're making
nickel 60 is a stable isotope of nickel
yeah forget it
so for the purposes of this problem
forget the N 3 equation we don't care
how much stable nickel 60 they were
making because it's a lot cheaper to get
it out of the ground
probably something like 10 orders of
magnitude cheaper yep
even one okay yep so the incident energy
I picked because one thing we had gone
over is that the thermal energy of the
neutron is around 0.025 evie which is
equal to 2.5 times 10 to the minus 8 MeV
so I took that value about 2.5 times 10
to the minus 8 MeV so around here and
just went up and on a log scale it looks
to be closest to two barns you can
always like get the actual value so if
you want to zoom right in I'm gonna keep
zooming in to the 10 to the minus 8 3
giin maybe not now you can set your
bounds accordingly so o 0 or negative
values yeah okay whatever let's just
read off the graph for now you can use
this tool to get the actual value but
for problems like this I think
estimating it from the graph is gonna be
fine when you get into 2205 and you're
like what's the actual flux in the
reactor to within 1% or something
estimating from the graph is no longer
allowable there are tabulated values of
these things oh yeah so you can actually
set the plot settings get the tables
cool Oh tabulated there we go
so you can read off values of the
cross-sections from a table like that
but for now since we want to make sure
to get this problem done let's just
stick with the graph so we don't care
about the end 3 equation we're also
going to say well let's not ignore Sigma
60 yet so how do we solve this set of
equations let's make a little separation
here first of all the easy one what's N
1 is a function of time
59 5 and what else and there's an n1
naught and there's a T because as you're
burning it out it matters how much time
you have doesn't this look eerily
similar to an N equals n naught e to the
minus lambda T again it's like
exponential artificial decay because
we're burning those things out for a
fixed amount of neutrons going in the
amount that we burn is proportional to
the amount that is there so that's the
burn rate that's the amount that's there
this is our artificial lambda so that
equations easy what we really want to
know is what is n2 as a function of time
that's the 60 million dollar question
and I'm not exaggerating there because
cobalt-60 is expensive so the question
I'm posing to you guys on the homework
so for those of you who've started
problems at 4 I'm gonna be swapping out
the noodle scratcher problem to this
problem that we're going to begin
together in class and you guys are going
to finish on the homework so I'm kind of
giving you a help on the homework what
is n 2 the amount of cobalt-60 in your
reactor as a function of time and what
is your profit for running the reactor
as a function of time assuming a few
things so let's set up some parameters
I'm gonna say that the Neutron flux is
the same as that in the MIT reactor
which is about 10 to the 14th neutrons
per centimeter squared per second we
already have all of our lambdas we have
all of our Sigma's I'm going to say that
the cost of running the reactor is and I
have a quote on this $1,000 per day
which is the same as 1 cent per second
not a bad rate to stick something in the
reactor right
it's not bad at all if you had to build
your own reactor your daily operating
costs would actually be a million
dollars a day who are a commercial power
plant so every time a plant goes down
you lose a million dollars a day plus
the lost electricity or whatever that
you have to buy so let's put that in
there and from the cost of this
hypothetical cobalt-60 source we know
that cobalt-60 runs about $100 per micro
Kure because these sources run for about
$100 and so the eventual problem that
we're going to set up here and you guys
are gonna solve on the homework and we
can keep going a little bit on Friday if
you want is at what point at what tea do
you shut off your reactor and extract
your cobalt 60 to maximize your profit
and this is an actual value judgment
that folks that make cobalt 60 have to
make how long do you keep your nickel
target in there and not hit diminishing
returns because you're always going to
be lets say increasing the amount of
cobalt 60 yeah increasing the amount of
cobalt 60 that you make if your source
is basically undeletable
until you reach some certain half-life
criterion but it might not make
financial sense to do so so let's start
getting the solution to end to let's see
so I'm going to rewrite our end to
equation and we can start solving it I'm
sorry that's adn to DT equals Sigma 59
flux and 1 minus lambda n 2 minus Sigma
60 flux and 2 so how do we go about
solving this differential equation
yep the old integrating factor first we
want to get rid of the n1 because that's
another variable and we've already
decided right here that N 1 is N 1
naught times e to the minus Sigma 59
flux t and we haven't specified what's N
1 naught
let's do that now last number we'll put
in is we started with a 100 gram source
of cobalt 59 that when we write it in
isotope parlance it sounds exotic but
that's actually the only stable isotope
of cobalt so that's just a lump of
cobalt from the ground that we stick in
so we know what N 1 naught is so we can
now rewrite this equation as let's just
go with n2 prime for shorthand and we'll
put everything on one side of the
equation so we'll have plus lambda plus
Sigma 65 and 2 minus Sigma 59 Phi times
e to the minus Sigma 59 Phi T equals
zero so what is our integrating factor
here
e to the lambda yep so it is e to the
integral of whatever's in front of our n
to lambda plus Sigma 60 Phi DT which
equals e to the lambda plus Sigma 60 Phi
T so we now multiply every term in this
equation by RM you are integrating
factor so let's say we have an to prime
times I'm just gonna use mu for
shorthand so it's gonna take a long time
to write plus let's see that right there
is like mu prime because we have if we
take the integral of mu times and let's
see yeah oh yeah this is right so we
have lambda plus Sigma 60 and 2 times mu
minus mu times Sigma 59 Phi e to the
minus Sigma 59 by T equals 0 this stuff
right here is like the expanded product
rule so we can write it more simply so
we can say n 2 times mu prime let's see
equals mu sigma 59 phi e to the minus
sigma 59 Phi times T so next we
integrate both sides and we get n 2
times mu equals let's see
let's expand everything out now so that
stuff would be Sigma 59 phi e to the
lambda plus sigma 60 Phi minus Sigma 59
Phi times T so if we integrate all of
that we're going to get Sigma 59 Phi I
think there's an end not missing here
isn't there
let's see there should be an n1 not
missing here yep there's an n1 not that
I dropped for some reason let's stick
that back in and one nut and and one not
and one nut over that stuff lambda plus
Sigma 60 Phi minus Sigma 59 Phi times
whatever is left e to the lambda plus 6
Sigma 60 Phi minus Sigma 59 Phi T plus C
so now we can say what's our integration
constant C the last thing we haven't
specified is our initial condition so
let's assume that when we started our
reactor
there was no cobalt-60 that makes for
the simplest initial condition so we can
substitute that in here so at T equals 0
n equals 0 so we would get 0 equals if T
is 0 then that just becomes Sigma 59 Phi
and 1 naught over lambda plus Sigma 60
Phi minus Sigma 59 Phi plus C and so
that makes things pretty easy because we
now see equals minus Sigma 59 Phi and 1
not over that stuff that I keep saying
over and over again and then we've
pretty much solved the equation the last
thing we have to do is divide by mu and
we'll end up with the same solution that
we got on Friday and the same solution
that we got on Tuesday so I realized the
second after I said it last time that oh
we can't just absorb some eetu the
something T into our integration
constant C because there's a variable T
in it so I would say look at this
derivation to know the whole solution
and so finally we end up with anyone
mind if I erase a little bit of this
stuff up top okay all erase the decay
diagram because we're not using that
anymore and hopefully everybody knows
our conversion factor so the end
solution and two of t would look like
let's see Sigma 59 Phi and one not over
lambda plus Sigma 65 minus Sigma 59 Phi
e let's see times e to the - what's
lambda 2 in this case lambda plus Sigma
65
t minus e to the minus sigma 59 5t and
that right there is our full equation
for n2 now you guys said let's make this
numerical okay
we have every numerical value already
chosen i've already plugged these into
the desmos thing so you can see
generally how this goes so we've solved
it theoretically so now let's make this
numerical and make some sort of a value
judgment right we know Sigma 59 because
we just looked that up
we know Phi we impose that as 10 to the
14th neutrons per second thing there it
is we know our lambda we know our we
don't know our Sigma 60 so we're just
going to forget that for now but the
point is for everything except time and
n 2 we have numerical constants for this
so once we plug it all in I modified the
decimals example from last time to have
the actual unit so you can see that our
fake l1 our lambda I'll call it lambda 1
equals Sigma 59 times Phi which is 20
Barnes 20 times 10 to the minus 24
centimeters squared times 10 to the 14th
neutrons per centimeter squared per
second and the centimeter squares cancel
that becomes to the minus 10 and we get
that our lambda 1 is like 2 times 10 to
the minus 9 per second okay our lambda 2
well we already have that 4.1 seven
times 10 to the minus 9 per second so
this is one of those cases where lambda
1 approximately equals lambda 2 so just
like you see in the book when you plug
in all the numbers you get
very similar equation which is to say
there's going to be some maximum of
cobalt-60 produced and in this case the
x-axis I have in seconds because that's
the units we're using for everything the
y-axis is number of atoms so right there
6 times 10 to the 23rd that's 1 mole so
at most you can make about a third of a
mole of cobalt-60 out of a hundred moles
of cobalt 59 which means you're never
actually going to have 1 mole of cobalt
60 because of the way that our natural
and our artificial decay constants work
out because they're fairly equal you're
never going to be able to convert and
harvest at all
that's the numerical output of this now
I have another question for you is the
top of this curve necessarily the profit
point for this reactor no good answer
why do you say no
[Music]
exactly that's what you guys are gonna
do on the homework I think I've done
we've done the hard part together here
and so now I want you guys to decide
given those profit parameters and I will
write them down on the pset how long do
you run your reactor to maximize your
cobalt-60 profit so this is one of those
examples where we did the whole
theoretical derivation we decided yes
let's escalate the situation for reality
everything works out just fine the final
answer
well you just tack on this extra like
artificial bit of decay from the
cobalt-60 being in the reactor but the
form of the equation is exactly the same
there's just a couple other constants in
it for reality then you plug in all the
numbers for the constants so you pretend
like that stuff is lambda2 and that
stuff is lambda 1 there's lambda 1 again
there's lambda 2 there's lambda 1 and
it's exactly the same equation will form
as the original solution that we had
when you plug in all the numbers you get
something remarkably similar to what's
in the book just scaled for actual units
of atoms and seconds is there a question
yeah sure if you can find it that's
great but I couldn't find it that easily
you can hunt through the different
databases and Janus to try to find it
but I'm not going to penalize it if you
can't find it if I couldn't find it so
yeah a lot of the homework is gonna be
redoing this derivation for yourself so
I want to make sure that you can go from
a set of equations
that models 8th actual physical solution
and I guarantee you you'll have another
physical solution on the exam solve them
using your knowledge of 1803 get some
sort of a solution which looks crazy but
it comes from straightforward math then
plug in some realistic numbers an answer
an actual question how long should you
run your reactor to maximize your profit
so it's kind of neat we've had we've
been here one month together you can
already start answering these value
judgment questions about running a
reactor and so again I don't know I
don't know who did but I'm glad you
asked is this filled mostly simulation
and the answer is no you actually have
to use math to make value judgments if
you want to go and make isotopes and
then you go and make the isotopes and
you sell them to people like me so I can
bring them into class and scare
unwitting members of the public
theoretically yeah hypothetical source
indeed so any questions on what we did
here from start to finish yep
the equation right in the middle there
yeah yeah yeah was like oh yeah that was
a mistake
thank you yep it probably means I was
talking and thinking at the same time
and forgot to write that but indeed it's
back everywhere else thank you yep this
lambda right here is the actual lambda
for cobalt-60 yep
this right here is just an analogy I'm
drawing to say that it's almost like
that stuff is lambda 1 that's our
original artificial decay constant and
this stuff here is like our lambda 2
because there's natural decay and then
there's reactor induced destruction yep
that comes from this solution right here
there's another interesting bit too did
we necessarily save let's see did we
necessarily say the no never mind that's
fine
that comes from let's trace it through
so mu contains no yeah it comes from C
that's right so we had it over here
because that's part of our solution for
let's see where we trace it back to it
starts off here in the differential
equation starts off here as well so
that's part of what's inside mu okay
that's where it came from so mu contains
this stuff yep then once you
it doesn't actually become land it
becomes e to the lambda plus 65 times G
yeah but when we when we do the
integration of that we don't get any
factors around oh yeah we do actually
there's a Mew stuck in right here and so
I just wanted to say that expanding this
term comes out to lambda plus Sigma 65
minus lambda of Sigma 59 Phi times T so
when you integrate this whole term and
again there's an N naught that should be
there you do bring this whole pile in
front of the T down on the bottom of the
equation so that's where it comes from
yeah cool I don't think there's any more
missing terms okay maybe time for a last
question because it is 10 o'clock yep
[Music]
I
so the crop the cross-section is almost
like if you fire a neutron at an atom
the bigger the atom appears to the
neutron the more likely it's going to
hit it so it's kind of a theoretical
construct to say if something has an
enormous cross-section it's like
shooting a bullet at a gigantic target
with a high probability of impact or
interaction something with a small
cross-section there's still only one
atom in the way but it's like you're
shooting a bullet at a tiny target and
have less of a chance of hitting it does
that make sense
cool they can can't relate it to a
physical cross-sectional area as far as
I know it's not like a certain nucleus
has a larger cross-sectional area
otherwise things like gadolinium which
has a cross-section of a hundred
thousand barns would just be a larger
atom and it's not in yeah Sean good
question they can be theoretically
calculated in some cases in the Yip Book
nuclear radiation interactions he does
go over how to calculate those from
quantum stuff and so you'll get a little
bit of that in 22:02 in terms of
predicting the cross section for
hydrogen and the cross section for water
and molecular water is not just the sum
of its parts that's the kind of crazy
part cross sections do change when you
put atoms and molecules together just
tend to tend to be at lower energies
around thermal energies and such some
can be let's say all of them probably
can be theoretically calculated just not
that easily but the really simple ones
you can predict titties theoretically
predicting the resonances in those cross
sections that's tough let's look at a
simple cross section like hydrogen
yes if you like if you know let's say
the full wavefunction for a given atom
or for all the electrons on an atom you
should be able to so let's do n total
for hydrogen much simpler this is the
kind of thing that can be predicted from
Theory quite easily in fact you will be
doing this in 22:02
the other one where was it the other one
no I don't expect you to be able to
predict this but you will learn why the
resonances are there and why they take
the shape that they do so if we want
last thing for a juco like three minutes
late but everyone's still here you can
go if you have to by the way I can't
keep you here if you want to know if you
want to make this equation more
realistic and account for every possible
energy in the reactor you can make these
cross-sections a function of energy and
integrate over the full energy range and
this is actually how it's done and you
will do this in 2205 where you'll be
able to take the energy dependent cross
section in tabulated or theoretical form
and then integrate this whole equation
and also account for the fact that the
flux as an energy component usually it
looks something like analyte water
reactor if this is energy and this is
flux there'll be a bit of a thermal
spike there won't be much going on in
the middle I'm sorry a fast spike and
there'll be a thermal spike and knowing
how many neutrons are at every energy
level what's the probability of every
Neutron at energy level interacting and
what are the cross-sections at every
energy level integrated over the full
energy range is what gets you the
accurate correct solution what we've
done here is called the one group
approximation where we've assumed that
all the neutrons have the same energy
thermal energy which is a okay
assumption for thermal light water
reactors and it'll get you a good
estimate the more neutrons you have at
different energies the less good that
estimate becomes yeah
that's that's the energy of a neutron
let's say you have a neutron at about
298 Kelvin from the maxwell-boltzmann
temperature distribution you can turn
that temperature into an average kinetic
energy and that average kinetic energy
will give you a velocity and that
velocity is around 2200 meters per
second and that average kinetic energy
happens to be about 0.025 evie so
thermalized neutrons like the ones
flying about in the reactor are moving
quite slowly at just 2200 meters a
second compared to the fast neutrons
which can be moving closer to the speed
of light not that close but much much
much closer cool I'll take it as a good
sign that you all voluntarily stayed a
little late so did you guys find this
example useful
you